oh that's one of the most serious crises
in the world I mean the United States
and Israel are in grave violation of
international humanitarian law it's not
my opinion that's the opinion of the
highest the world's highest judicial
authority the International Court of
Justice which declared that the
provisions of the of the Geneva
Convention Fourth Geneva Convention
apply to the occupied territories which
means that all movement of population
into those areas all the settlements are
illegal the Court determined
authoritative Lee that the wall that
Israel is building which is clearly by
now an annexation wall is in it so facto
violation of international humanitarian
law insofar as it's there to protect
settlers which is maybe 80 to 85 percent
of it the Bush administration is the
first one to have officially declared
support for Israel's policies of
takeover of what's valuable to it in the
occupied territories which makes the two
countries in severe and of course the
u.s. funds it and provides the
diplomatic and military support required
for us power centers appear to be pretty
happy with this the US corporations for
example don't seem to object to having a
highly militarized ally with a
high-technology
very loyal because has no choice once it
decided to move towards to prefer
expansion through security as it did
years ago and they are certainly
technically they're capable of pursuing
the policies that they are following the
major Arab states may not like it but
I'm going to try to do anything about it
the rest of Europe refuses us to take
more than a passive role so that the
the Palestinians are the nation is being
destroyed that's a rare event in history
for a nation to face destruction but
it's happening and it's happening the
United States and Israel at the moment
or and in fact for many years have been
internationally isolated in their
refusal to accept a diplomatic
settlement in accord with what has been
an overwhelming international consensus
of kind of through state settlement on
the international border with some
modification of borders and they still
are rejecting it alone the Arab states
have explicitly come out in favor of it
or Han has stated its agreement with
these position of the Arab states Hamas
is called for it
Europe of course and the non-aligned
countries of course but the u.s. has
overwhelming power in that region and if
it stands in the way of a settlement it
won't take place with all the conflicts
that this could can lead to and for the
local populations a very serious but
even with ramifications else